the Joe Rogan experience now we're like
such grown-ups in our pantry we have
like a little liquor section right and
you have like all there's you know yeah
I have a wine fridge
yeah but in the old days you couldn't
because you just drank it and it's gone
right you know yeah I want to interview
you I want to interview you for a minute
okay okay how comfortable do you ever
tell your listeners about about the
comedy stuff you're working on or do you
like to keep a big secret
I tell them some things I don't like to
give up premises cheers sir you don't
like to give up premises
I mean punchlines Oh say like a subject
I'm working on you do or don't give up
subjects well I want to gauge you about
a subject that we were texting about
about the yeah missionary yeah yeah yeah
I just don't understand this is good I
know that you will I like it I know that
you will have I'm knowing you and how
good you are at what you do I know
you'll have done it but don't understand
how you could have had a novel thought
about the missionary yes who got killed
just to refresh people's dessert there's
an island East Sentinel what swayed by
my fish actor's island called Sentinel
island really yeah no one lives on it
I've been passed it many times and if
you haven't been shot at it's North
Sentinel island goes north sorry north
central islands and they might my Shack
is east sentinel north central out you
know better so you should tell people
what it is i want to go to your shack a
little bit really yeah let's let's next
one instead of a hunting trip let's do a
fishing trip i would love to have a half
gallon come out there and we'll catch
some halibut so you weren't you're not
interested bringing your family yeah we
do that we kind of take a family
approach okay more and more no well you
could flip it over you kids like
flipping rocks and songs on the rock my
youngest loves fishing loves it
rod whooping she loves everything yeah
she's really big enough how young is the
youngest nine oh yeah perfect but no I
want to get like I just can't
I can't I've thought about and thought
about it and I can't think not that I
don't have faith in you I just can't
think of what it take would be yeah the
problem is if I explained it what the
take is it would [ __ ] up the bit for
people that haven't seen
I'll show you night tonight I'm going
tonight I can't wait to go see but I
just wanted to explain off air explain
off air okay yeah are you feeling good
about the day yeah yeah it's a
fascinating subject you know the guy
commander Maurice of a doll Portman you
know who that guy is no mmm he was the
the pervert that traveled around from
island to island measuring guys and
taking weird photos oh yeah Roman
soldiers
I read the I read a big piece about this
which actually sent to you to see if
you'd read it too yeah I read you said
you read everything about it yeah I've
read quite a few things about it because
there was a guy on Twitter his name is
respectable law at respectable law and
he posted a whole series of things he
he'd actually been studying this case or
this this place before because of this
pervert guy and so when this man this
missionary showed up on that island he
murdered like he knew all about the
history of this island so he made like a
chain of posts on Twitter which were
really interesting informative and then
I started going deep into it I've read
the guys journals the journals were
hilarious my life the kid that got
killed no the guy the pervert the
English the English pervert and the
1800s probably wrecked like that whole
area for those people because they had
this idea of what white men are now
these people don't have a written
language and they they just have stories
so they probably still have stories of
these white men that come carrying
diseases and want to touch your dick and
measure them yeah so this is a guy he
was in the swimming sure I remember us
right he was in like skull morphology
but with sexual organs well he was it's
hard to tell what he was into but it was
it's so obviously perverted like it's it
seems like he was doing sexual stuff
with these people trying to legitimize
it by yeah I mean like yeah just
measuring them and and and doing
detailed descriptions of their sex
organs and know who's really into that
that seemed very important to him and he
sir he survived the island I guess I
wish to go with my new uh my new Laird
Hamilton turmeric coffee or the whiskey
I mix it up back
it's really interesting it's like it's
like soup yes with the off unit it's
very good for you too
like I said that turmeric you know
people think of it as curry because it's
a great spice for food but it's a it's a
potent anti-inflammatory very very good
for you know it's good so I'll have to
wait and see what your take on it is are
you I'm almost done interviewing you um
are you drawn to that are you drawn to
that idea
I certainly am which idea you'd get that
you'd go and hang out and spend time
with yes uncontacted people well you've
done it in what what part of South
America will you have will you well yeah
they're not on contact not assembly not
uncontacted but yes some tribes that
like the Chi Minh a and the Micucci and
whopper Shan are all tribes in northern
South America who have long long history
of contact and engagement with the
outside world but individuals who can
still very much like hanging out with
individuals who aren't that old who in
their youth were very much like living a
hunter-gatherer lifestyle with it with a
mix of native materials and also some
Western materials this is Guiana Guyana
and Bolivia people that you know people
that would still make their bows from
native materials people that grew up
using canoes that were made like hand
you know hand dug dugouts using plant
toxins to kill fish but also like you
know also other very modern stuff like
one of these guys that I really
appreciate hanging out with I mean the
guys got an email address but I might
have told you this story before he's got
an email address but he also told us
about we interviewed him on our show on
our podcast and and he's telling me
about how there peccaries their white
lip peccaries aren't around right now
because there's a shaman in another
village who's jealous of their village
for being so prompt
and has locked their peccaries up inside
of a mountain and that they're training
their own shaman to free the packer ease
from the mountain and you can shoot this
dude and email